eine geisterstadt in der wüste vergiftet
von einem unnatürlichen gewässer es
wirkt apokalyptisch hier ist vor nicht
allzu langer zeit etwas geschehen
eine verfallene siedlung in tschechien
mit rätselhafter vergangenheit wir reden
hier von umweltschäden in milliarden
höhe
eine berüchtigte anstalt mitten im
dschungel von zweifelhafter berühmtheit
es ist die hölle auf erden und eine
festung in den norwegischen bergen die
zum schauplatz eines gewagten
kriegseinsatzes wurde es war eine der
bemerkenswertesten operationen des
krieges
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
hoch in den norwegischen bergen und 160
kilometer westlich der hauptstadt oslo
steht ein gebäude das beinahe den
verlauf der geschichte geändert hätte
die geschichte wurde später mehrfach
verfilmt
dieses imposante gebäude mit seinen
riesigen fenstern über dem tal welchem
zweck diente es hole
man erkennt dass es sich dabei um eine
große industrieanlage handelt ihre
errichtung muss äußerst aufwendig
gewesen sein
die abgeschiedene lage und die
stacheldrahtzäune lassen vermuten dass
sich hier etwas sehr wertvolles befand
es wird sogar heute noch streng bewacht
aber es ist der schutz vor dem gebäude
der die eigentliche hauptrolle spielt
dies sind die überreste einer anderen
struktur die einst diese abgelegenen
berge dominierte
was hat sich hier abgespielt ein gebäude
hat überdauert ein zweites ganz
offensichtlich nicht
in den unterirdischen gebäudeteilen
findet sich massenhaft verbogener stahl
dort unten ist alles zerstört es müssen
enorme kräfte freigesetzt worden sein
die geschichte dieser industrieanlage
reicht zurück zum beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
[Musik]
männer einer spezialeinheit setzten
später ihr leben aufs spiel um sie zu
zerstören
die umgebung die fed hinweise auf den
zweck des gebäudes
es gibt ganz eindeutig eine verbindung
mit der landschaft und vor allem mit dem
wasserfall von den bergen verlaufen
riesige rohre ins gebäude
dies ist das wasserkraftwerk wem burg
erbaut 1911 von der norsk hydro
büros ist expertin für seine geschichte
das ist die maschinenhalle hier wurde
die hydro elektrische energie gewonnen
bei seiner fertigstellung im jahr 1911
war dies das größte kraftwerk der welt
im wm ort soll dünger für die
landwirtschaft produziert werden um die
rapide wachsende weltbevölkerung
ernähren zu können
wo eine der großen herausforderungen für
wissenschaftler im frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts war die produktion von mehr
dünger für die landwirtschaft
und verdünner braucht man stickstoff
alte chemische prozess zur herstellung
von stickstoff ist äußerst
energieaufwändig
mit all seinen bergen und flüssen hat
norwegen wasserkraft im überfluss der
wasserfall trifft mit hoher
geschwindigkeit auf die turbinen und
lässt sie rotieren dadurch entsteht
elektrizität in den generatoren
doch im untergeschoss der heute
verlassenen anlage findet sich ein raum
mit spezialgeräten für gänzlich andere
zwecke
hier wurde ursprünglich etwas sehr gutes
für die menschheit getan er bei dieser
ort besaß zugleich auch ein tödliches
potenzial
bei der dünger herstellung der gewinnung
von stickstoff entstand ein leben
produkt und dieses nebenprodukt war
schweres wasser
schweres wasser ist sehr komplex seiner
herstellung ist schwierig und
kostspielig
wie gewöhnliches wasser enthält es zwei
wasserstoffatomen und einem
sauerstoffatom die beiden wasserstoff
atome sind allerdings mit einem
zusätzlichen neutronen angereichert dass
ihr gewicht und zehn prozent erhöht
diese art von wasserstoff wird als
deuterium bezeichnet eine schwere form
von wasserstoff in der natur ist es
ungefährlich doch seine atomare struktur
macht es zu einem nützlichen hilfsmittel
bei der produktion von atomwaffen
nachdem hitler die welt 1939 in den
krieg gestürzt hat ist er entsprechend
interessiert daran
hitlers wissenschaftler brauchten das
schwere wasser um damit kernreaktionen
zu verlangsamen und zu verlängern ein
wichtiger schritt für die entwicklung
von waffenfähigem plutonium
die anlage war weltweit die einzige die
schweres wasser in nennenswerter menge
er stellte deshalb war sie wichtig für
das deutsche atomwaffenprogramm
1940 marschieren deutsche truppen im
neutralen norwegen ein und besetzen auch
das kraftwerk in wenigen monaten wird
die produktion von schwerem wasser
verzehnfacht die alliierten wissen dass
sie den krieg nur gewinnen können wenn
sie die deutschen daran hindern eine
einsatzfähige atomwaffen fertigzustellen
der wichtigste wissenschaftler auf
alliierter seite ist der norweger leif
kronstadt
kannte die anlage in allen details denn
er hatte sie mit entworfen er überzeugte
die briten davon dass es keinerlei
wirkung hätte das kraftwerk nur aus der
luft zu bombardieren weil die schwer
wasseranlage im untergeschoss lag auf
diese weise würde man nur die gebäude
darüber zerstören
ton stadtplan ist gefährlich und äußerst
riskant eine spezialeinheit soll in das
kraftwerk eindringen und die
entscheidende anlage darin zerstören
aber wem org ist eine natürliche festung
und wird streng bewacht
es liegt mitten in dieser
gebirgslandschaft da fährt man nicht
einfach die straße rauf die anlage ist
leicht zu schützen weil sie so abgelegen
in den bergen steht
im oktober 1942 springen vier
norwegische fallschirmjäger als
vorauskommando über den gebiet ab der
plan sieht vor dass sie zu ihren
britischen kollegen stoßen die im
folgemonat als teil der operation
freshman eintreffen ihre mission in
viborg eindringen und die anlage
zerstören
der erste versuch ging katastrophal
schief am 19 november 1942 mussten zwei
gleiter mit britischen soldaten in den
bergen notlanden die überlebenden wurden
von den deutschen entdeckt und
erschossen
trotz dieses verlustreichen rückschlags
bleibt den alliierten keine andere wahl
als es erneut zu versuchen
im februar 1943 läuft die operation
gamma site an
eine der wohl dramatischsten und
wichtigsten militärmissionen des zweiten
weltkriegs
sechs norwegische spezialkräfte wurden
eingeflogen sie sprang ein britischer
uniform ab damit die deutschen im falle
ihrer gefangennahme keine rache an der
norwegischen bevölkerung nehmen würden
der plan sieht vor sich mit dem ersten
team zusammen zu schließen dem es
gelungen ist vier monate lang in der
eisigen wildnis zu überleben
sie landeten sicher aber weit vom
zielpunkt entfernt in sachen versorgung
und logistik war das eine katastrophe
denn sie hatten einfach nichts dabei
nach einem zermürbenden fünftägigen
marsch durch knietiefen schnee treffen
die beiden teams schließlich aufeinander
jetzt da sie vereint waren konnten sie
endlich das scheinbar unmögliche
versuchen in die anlage eindringen und
hitlers atompläne stoppen die einheit
diskutierte darüber auf welchem weg man
ins gebäude gelangen sollte eine
möglichkeit war die überquerung der
hängebrücke aber die wurde bewacht
nach der fehlgeschlagenen operation
freshman hatten die deutschen den schutz
des kraftwerks verstärkt damit kommt die
querung der streng bewachten brücke
nicht mehr in frage das team muss einen
anderen weg finden
es bleiben nur zwei äußerst gefährliche
optionen
entweder nähern sich die männer über
einen militärisch gesicherten
gebirgspass voller landminen oder sie
klettern durch eine etwa 150 meter tiefe
schlucht
sie beschlossen dorthin ab und auf der
anderen seite wieder hinauf zu klettern
dort verliefen schienen und die schienen
waren nicht verdient
auf dem gelände selbst wussten sie wie
sie ins gebäude kam und wo sie die
sprengladungen platzieren mussten denn
trotz dort hatte sie genauestens
instruiert
in diesem raum fand der sabotage akt
statt der anführer der operation
platzierte sprengladungen an den schwer
wasserbehältern
unbemerkt von den wachen gelangen die
männer in den schwer wasser
produktionsbereich dort platzieren sie
kurze 30 sekunden zündschnüre an den
elektrolyse kammern in denen das schwere
wasser produziert wird dann entkommen
sie unbemerkt
[Musik]
die mission ist ein voller erfolg
explosionen erschüttern das werk und
zerstören etwa eine halbe tonne schweres
wasser
es war eine der bemerkenswertesten
operationen des krieges
im chaos nach den explosionen gelingt es
der gesamten einheit zu entkommen
niemand wird bei dem einsatz getötet und
es wird kein einziger schuss abgegeben
die einheit überwindet die schlucht und
teilt sich dann in kleinere gruppen auf
die sich ins neutrale schweden absetzen
[Musik]
letztlich gelingt es allen männern zu
ihrer norwegischen kompanie
zurückzukehren die in großbritannien
stationiert ist
ihre geschichte wurde seitdem mehrfach
verfilmt unter anderem mit kirk douglas
und richard harris
wäre die anlage in warburg nicht
zerstört worden hätte hitler womöglich
atomwaffen entwickeln können
[Musik]
zwar gelingt es den deutschen in der
folge die schwer wasser produktion in
viborg wieder aufzunehmen aber da ist es
bereits zu spät
deutschland fehlen die ressourcen um das
kriegsgeschehen durch den einsatz von
atomwaffen zu beeinflussen
in späteren jahren werden die
überlastete der schwer wasseranlage
abgerissen
heute befindet sich in villmar kein
museum das auch der männer gedenkt die
ihr leben im kampf gegen einen
übermächtigen feind riskierten
[Musik]
weshalb diese männer gehören zu den
großen helden norwegens
wäre operation gamma zeit gescheitert
würde die welt heute vielleicht anders
aussehen
mitten in der kalifornischen wüste rund
240 kilometer südöstlich von los angeles
liegt ein ungewöhnlicher see
dieses gewässer wirkt ein bisschen
unheimlich irgendetwas stimmt damit
nicht
an seinen ufern verstreut finden sich
die bröckelnden überreste einer fern
erscheinenden vergangenheit
es wirkt apokalyptisch überall gibt es
gebäude und infrastruktur aber alles ist
verfallen und heruntergekommen
die dort strahlt kein leben aus eher das
gegenteil
leerstehende gebäude und rostige relikte
zeugen davon dass hier einst viele
menschen lebten
man sieht die überreste eines wohnmobils
ein altes ehemaliges hotel hier ist von
nicht allzu langer zeit etwas geschehen
aber was hat sich hier abgespielt
liefert die umgebung womöglich hinweise
der untergrund ist lebendig im schlamm
steigen gasblasen auf die tief aus der
erde kommen ist das ein natürliches
phänomen
was hat sich verändert und was hat es
mit diesem gewässer auf sich
noch vor 40 jahren war diese region
dicht besiedelt ausgelegt auf
hunderttausende besucher
heute leben hier nur noch wenige
menschen
john kerry otis zog in den 70er jahren
hierher
es war schön hier es gab neben
tankstellen und restaurants wir waren
eine große gemeinschaft zu der viele
leute gehörten den ort heute so trostlos
zu sehen tut weh
wer immer noch hier ist wird wohl bis zu
seinem tod ihr bleiben
in den 60er jahren ist dies ein
boomender urlaubsort mit mehr als einer
million besuchern jährlich
nur zwei autostunden von los angeles
entfernt wird es in kürzester zeit zu
einem beliebten ausflugsziel für
hollywoods reiche und schöne
in den guten jahren war das rat pack
hier sammy davis junior frank sinatra
dean martin barbra streisand und eine
menge anderer leute das war bevor palm
springs wurde was es heute ist an den
sonnenverwöhnten stränden drängen sich
die badegäste und angler freuen sich
über die großen fischbestände
es gab regatten draußen auf dem see
waren haufenweise yachten das angeln war
eine freude
[Musik]
diesen zeiten sind heute nur noch schwer
vorstellbar all diese siedlungen sind
heruntergekommen niemand will dort mehr
etwas investieren der grund dafür ist
das große problem dass sie alle
miteinander verbindet das wasser
dies sind die geisterstädte am sollten
sie einem see der durch einen zufall
zustande kam und dieser staubigen wüsten
region eine kurze blütezeit bescherte
doch wie konnte mitten in einer so
trockenen region ein so großer see
entstehen und warum ähnelt die gegend
jetzt einer post-apokalyptischen ödnis
zu beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wollten sehr viele menschen den colorado
river nutzen um ihre farmen in der
umliegenden wüste zu bewässern der
colorado river entspringt hoch in den
rocky mountains und mündet nach gut 2300
kilometern in den golf von kalifornien
um die wichtige land wirtschaftsregion
des imperial valley mit wasser zu
versorgen
konstruieren ingenieure einen kanal der
einen teil des flusses ableitet aber den
mächtigen colorado zu bändigen ist nicht
so leicht
ingenieure haben gern die kontrolle aber
wenn man es mit naturgewalten zu tun hat
weiß man nie ganz genau was passiert
1905 colorado river nach sintflutartigen
regenfällen über die ufer ändert seinen
verlauf und fließt westlich in eine
damals trockene wüsten senke
pro tag laufen 170 millionen kubikmeter
wasser hinein so entsteht ein see dessen
wasserspiegel täglich um 18 zentimeter
am streckt es
dauerte zwei jahre bis die ingenieure
einen weg fanden um den fluss zu stoppen
und bis dahin war die senke schon gut
gefüllt
die sie schuften praktisch alles um sich
herum
mit dem tourismus kam das geld und das
wollten leute für sich nutzen
es entstanden hotels und stand anlagen
die leute kamen aus los angeles um sich
dieses brandneue binnengewässer
anzusehen man sprach von der
mit einer fläche von fast 1000
quadratkilometern wird er sollten sie
zum größten süßwassersee kaliforniens
der planungs unfall sorgt nicht nur für
einen touristenboom er verwandelt auch
die einst lebensfeindliche landschaft
durch das wasser in der wüste wurde der
boden in weiten gebieten fruchtbar und
landwirtschaftlich nutzbar
die landwirtschaft ist sehr wichtig für
die gegend das imperial county ist als
brodkorb kaliforniens bekannt bis in den
mittleren westen hinein wird obst und
gemüse gegessen das hier geerntet wird
anfangs war das toll die öde trockene
gegend lief voll mit süßwasser aus den
bergen und es entstand diese großartige
oase inmitten der ansonsten unwirtlichen
wüste
was als unglück beginnt ist schon bald
als wüsten wunder bekannt aber der
erfolg dieses künstlichen kalifornischen
sees ist nur von kurzer dauer schon bald
wandelt sich das wunder zum alptraum
das ist das stadtzentrum dieses gebäude
hier war mal die bank zur glanzzeit
staute sich der verkehr draußen leute
rannten kreuz und quer über die straße
ohne nach links oder rechts zu schauen
schließlich waren sie hier um sich zu
vergnügen
niemand ahnt dass derweil eine
ökologische zeitbombe
vorsichtig
wenn man sich heute den strand ansieht
muss man kein experte sein um zu merken
dass die landschaft unnatürlich und
fremdartig wirkt
alles ist mit dieser feinen pulvrigen
staubschicht bedeckt
die einst idyllische strände sehen jetzt
völlig anders aus john curtiss ehefrau
marie hat damals selbst miterlebt wie
sich das blatt in der region wendete
viele denken dass sand aber es sind
millionen fische retten wirbel
krebstiere es sieht hübsch aus aber das
sind aber millionen tote fische
ihr beginnt man fragt sich ist das eine
umweltkatastrophe
dies ist ein geologisch sehr aktiver
bereich der erde nahe der san andreas
verwerfung
besonders ungewöhnlich ist die gegend in
der all diese [ __ ] vor sich hin
brodeln
die landschaft ist der fremdartig ist
etwas geschehen dass die umgebung ganz
plötzlich verändert und probleme
geschaffen hat hat
sich hier eine naturkatastrophe
abgespielt oder sind dafür menschen
verantwortlich
jedenfalls verraten die brodelnden
bereiche dass es sich hier nicht um ein
normales gewässer handelt
auf den ersten blick könnte man meinen
eine naturkatastrophe habe zu den
problemen geführt aber wenn man genauer
hinsieht wird klar dass es keine
natürlichen ursachen hat sondern von
menschen gemacht ist der einzige
wasserzulauf des sollten sie es stammt
aus den 200.000 hektar
landwirtschaftlich genutzten gebiet das
ihn umgibt und dort liegt das problem
die enormen vorteile die sich aus der
industriellen landwirtschaft ergeben
haben einen hohen preis
es ist dass der tiefste punkt in der
region ist gibt es keinen zu und ablauf
wie bei einem gewöhnlichen see was dort
hineinläuft bleibt im ökosystem
er wird immer salziger und
konzentrierter während das wasser
verdampft man kennt das vom toten meer
in israel
hier entsteht das problem weil das
zufließende wasser durch diverse
bewässerte farmen fließt und dadurch
stark mit pestiziden und düngemitteln
belastet ist
dabei entsteht dann diese chemische
brühe
für die fische können nicht atmen sie
sterben und werden an den strand gespült
wir hatten hier auf rund einem kilometer
tote fische liegen es war grauenhaft ein
fürchterlicher gestank niemand wollte
sich am strand aufhalten
schließlich fänden die touristenströme
die einst blühenden städte leeren sich
und es kommt noch schlimmer
innerhalb von 15 jahren sinkt der
wasserspiegel um fast zweieinhalb meter
so dass über 8000 hektar des sees
austrocknen in diesem bereich der
wüstefeld so gut wie kein regen also
begann der seiten see auszutrocknen
jetzt wird dieser feine staub voller
salzfrei gesetzt indem auch lauter
giftige pestizide und anderes
konzentriert sind
der wind verteilt den wüstensand und mit
ihm die chemikalien hunderte kilometer
weit über amerika das ist eine enorme
gesundheitsgefährdung für die
bevölkerung
strände an denen sich sonst
sonnenanbeter tummelten sind nun
lebloser giftiger morast ein trauriger
anblick für jene die den ort zu seiner
blütezeit kannten das hat auswirkungen
wir haben deswegen die höchste rate die
leute werden krank wenn sie das zeug
einatmen
in jedem touristen ort gibt es auch
menschen die dort zu hause sind sie
ziehen ihre kinder dort groß leben und
sterben dort und find diese menschen ist
so etwas sehr sehr traurig
[Musik]
heute stehen die hotels und restaurants
leer sie sind nur noch verblasste
erinnerungen an eine kurze glanzzeit
ich dachte immer der ort würde wieder so
werden wie in den 60er und 70er jahren
aber die traurige wahrheit ist das wird
nicht passieren
[Musik]
im tropischen regenwald von
französisch-guayana an der nordostküste
südamerikas
findet sich eine abgelegene siedlung mit
einer finsteren vergangenheit
einige der gebäude sehen recht hübsch
aus erbaut im kolonialstil mit
traditionellen fensterläden aber weiter
auf dem gelände stößt man auf eine
andere art von bauten
man sieht dass dort viele menschen
gelebt haben sie haben im wahrsten sinne
des wortes buchen hinterlassen an den
wänden wenn man sich umsieht wird
deutlich dass dies ein ort voller leid
und trauer ist
es wirkt als kämen die wende auf einen
zu man fühlt sich zunehmend unwohl und
spürt die düstere geschichte des ortes
man erkennt schnell dieser ort war einst
eine art gefängnis und das leben eines
berühmten insassen hier sowie seine
gewagte flucht wurden zum
internationalen bestseller
aber entsprach seine geschichte den
tatsachen oder hat er sie ausgeschmückt
da gibt es viele fragezeichen
die faszinierende geschichte hinter
diesen bröckelnden mauern beginnt im
frankreich des 19 jahrhunderts
die franzosen hatten probleme mit ihren
gefängnissen sie waren überfüllt und
teuer
die sklaverei wurde damals weltweit
abgeschafft auch in den kolonien um die
probleme der steigenden kriminalität und
des mangels an arbeitern in frankreichs
überseegebieten zu lösen setzt napoleon
der dritte auf eine radikale lösung
die franzosen begann ihre kolonien in
übersee dafür zu nutzen dort ihre
schlimmsten verbrecher unterzubringen so
verschwanden gefährliche straftäter aus
frankreich das französische gefängnis
system wurde entlastet und frankreichs
kolonien bekamen kostenlose
arbeitskräfte
1850 wird diese strafkolonie am fluss
maroni als erste station für
strafgefangene eingerichtet die zu
zwangsarbeit in französisch guayana
verurteilt wurden
es ist kein zufall dass diese art der
bestrafung oft in den unwirtlichsten und
abgelegensten gebieten der europäischen
kolonialmächte stattfand
bis 1946 werden rund 70.000 straftäter
über den atlantik nach süd amerika
verschifft aber erst zwei jahrzehnte
später wird dieser ort weltweit
berüchtigt an den wänden sind namen
verewigt und besonders einer davon macht
deutlich was für eine unglaubliche
geschichte dieser ort hat
ein berühmter insasse lebte hier
der mann ist eine legende der mysteriöse
gefangenen der seine liebe zu
schmetterlingen auf der brust tätowiert
trug
1969 veröffentlicht er seinen bericht
über das leben hier und landet damit
einen internationalen bestseller vier
jahre später wird die geschichte mit
steve mcqueen und dustin hoffman in den
hauptrollen unter dem titel papillon
verfilmt
dies ist das berüchtigte straflager von
salon die maroni teil eines komplexes
ausharrten strafkolonie in
französisch-guyana der fremdenführer
ronny kennt die geschichten
wurden die härteren jungs untergebracht
das hier ist die zelle von papillon
bürgerliche karriere alias papillon
da auf dem boden hat er sich verewigt
cabrios geschichte beginnt als ds
27-jährige ok cherie er im jahr 1931
hier eintrifft
doch entscheiden wird sie sich an einem
anderen ort der noch furchteinflößender
ist
alisar er wurde zu lebenslanger haft mit
zehn jahren zwangsarbeit verurteilt für
einen mord den er nach eigener aussage
nicht begangen hatte
neben der belastung durch die
zwangsarbeit herrschte dort auch noch
ein sehr warmes tropisches klima das
allerlei krankheiten mit sich brachte
malaria oder gelbfieber typhus sogar
lepra
erschreckende 40 prozent aller
neuankömmlinge versterben innerhalb des
ersten jahres
fast täglich kommt es zu gewalt unter
den gefangenen hier gilt nur das recht
des stärkeren
[Musik]
wer schwäche zeigt wird bestraft sie
nehmen dir dein essen weg du wirst
geschlagen man nimmt ihr alles die
gefangenen werden regelmäßig von den
wärtern geschlagen wer sich zur wehr
setzt wird gnadenlos bestraft mit dem
tod durch die guillotine
die hinrichtungen werden im offenen
bereich zwischen den beiden bereiten
reihen durchgeführt
[Musik]
das fallbeil schnell der herab und st
und dann begannen alle hier zu singen
sie sangen für ihre toten freunde
es ist kein zufall dass es neben diesen
straflagern große friedhöfe gab die
meisten die dorthin geschickt wurden
kamen nicht mehr zurück
ein teil der kritik an den straflagern
in französisch-guyana bezog sich darauf
dass es dort nicht um resozialisierung
ging menschen die sich nicht wehren
konnten wurden als sklaven benutzt
wenig überrascht gibt es viele
fluchtversuche die jedoch nur selten von
erfolg gekrönt sind die gefängnisgebäude
gleichen einander überall auf der welt
doch hier diente die umgebung als
erweiterung des gefängnisses im
regenwald gibt es spinnen giftige
schlangen und tausendfüßler
fleischfressende ameisen auch der fluss
bietet keine zuflucht denn darin wimmelt
es von piranhas und kaimanen
trotz der aussichtslosen lage gibt die
hoffnung nicht auf zu entkommen er
versucht es mehrfach ohne erfolg
wegen dieser fluchtversuche wurde er
schließlich auf die teufelsinsel verlegt
die als ausbruchsicher aller
strafkolonie galt
die ehe du diable ist der gefürchtetste
ort im verzug system von
französisch-guyana
die kahle felsige insel liegt rund 15
kilometer vor der küste inmitten hey
verseuchter gewässer
dort zu landen ist schon schlimm genug
papier wird noch dazu zwei jahren
einzelhaft verurteilt
die zellen für die einzelhaft gehören
eindeutig zu den schlimmsten orten dort
man ist eingeschlossen völlig allein
ohne belüftung oder fenster oder sonst
irgendwas ganz allein mit seinen
gedanken
doch nach 13 jahren haft und neun
fluchtversuchen gelingt es papier
tatsächlich von der teufelsinsel zu
entkommen
er baute sich ein floß aus kokosnüssen
und schlug sich nach venezuela durch
dort baute er sich eine existenz als
restaurantbetreiber auf und schrieb ein
buch über seine geschichte bis heute ist
nicht ganz geklärt wie viel davon
tatsächlich wahr ist
ein bericht des französischen
justizministeriums über das lager auf
der teufelsinsel kommt zu dem schluss
dass sharifs darstellung zu höchstens
zehn prozent der wahrheit entspricht
andere urteilen die geschichten im buch
sein ausgedacht oder übertrieben jahre
später gibt ein anderer ehemaliger
gefangener an er nicht scharia sei
besagter papillon
manche halten das buch für eine mischung
aus eigenen erlebnissen und erzählungen
dritter sicher ist dass die bedingungen
dort unglaublich hart waren
die kontroverse um karriere es berichte
hält bis heute an er stirbt
1973 an kehlkopfkrebs und mit ihm wohl
auch die wahrheit über sein leben
schließlich erreichen die berichte über
die barbarischen zustände vor ort auch
frankreich
als die französische öffentlichkeit von
den unmenschlichen bedingungen erfuhr
reagierte sie mit entsetzen und
damit war das ende dieser lager nur eine
frage der zeit
ein jahrhundert nach ihrer eröffnung
wird die strafkolonie geschlossen und
die verbleibenden gefangenen kehren in
die heimat zurück bis auf 300 insassen
die sich weigern zu gehen
sie blieben in französisch-guyana denn
es war das einzige leben das sie noch
kannten und sich vorstellen konnten
heute gibt es hier glücklicherweise
keine gefangenen mehr und die
verfallenen gebäude und lehrern zellen
sind alles was noch an dieses düstere
kapitel des kolonialismus erinnert
80 kilometer nordöstlich der
tschechischen hauptstadt prag erstreckt
sich eine wildnis so weit das auge
reicht
es ist eine wunderschöne gegend ländlich
ruhig wie gemacht für eine
tageswanderung
wenn ich sieht man sich das gelände
genauer an stößt man auf siedlungen es
müssen also einst menschen in dieser
gegend gelebt haben und zwar für längere
zeit
nicht weit entfernt stehen gebäude aus
jüngeren zeiten
man sieht dass diese gegend über einen
längeren zeitraum bebaut wurde es gibt
gebäude aus verschiedenen epochen ein
ziemlicher mix
jegliche spuren der menschen die auf
diesen geisterhaften treppen unterwegs
waren sind längst verschwunden
das ungewöhnlichste ist dieses gebäude
mit wirklich seltsame atmosphäre
es gibt ein großes bad mit duschen und
eine apparatur durch die man
hindurchgehen kann
draußen finden sich patronenhülsen
zerfurchte wände und verbogenes metall
der ort wirft fragen auf man fragt sich
was da los ist es lassen sich immer
wieder menschen nieder doch dann
verschwinden sie wieder warum
die mysteriösen bauten stehen in einem
teil von tschechien der eine bewegte
geschichte hat
der grund für ihre errichtung findet
sich in den nachkriegsjahren
bereits in der tschechoslowakei nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg die kommunisten an die
macht kamen wurde das land zu einem
satelliten start der udssr
die tschechoslowakei grenzte an die
bundesrepublik deutschland
das war die frontlinie des kalten
krieges
dieses weitläufige gelände in roskow war
einst der größte sowjetische stützpunkt
in der tschechoslowakei
ausschließlich rotarmisten hatten
zutritt zu der streng geheimen anlage
modernes militär braucht große
übungsgelände nicht nur um die truppen
unterzubringen sondern auch um
artillerie abzufeuern
selbst heute sind nicht alle bereiche
des truppenübungsplatzes frei zugänglich
der pensionierte polizist václav billig
ist in den siebziger jahren ganz in der
nähe beschäftigt als pyrotechniker räumt
er gefahrstoffe auf dem gelände des
stützpunkts
ich kam 1976 hierher als
bombenentschärfer für die polizei damals
nannte man sie chor für die nationale
sicherheit
auf dem gelände hatten wir eine spreng
grube wo wir die munition zerstörten
aber warum ist es den sowjets so wichtig
zu verbergen was sich hier abspielt und
welche bedrohung davon ausgeht
im verlauf des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ist dieses gebiet gegenstand erbitterter
territorial kämpfe in europa
in den anfangsjahren nutzen dass die
streitkräfte österreich-ungarns als
übungsgelände nach deutschlands
besetzung der tschechoslowakei für die
wehrmacht hier manöver durch in dieser
region lebten tausende deutschstämmige
und hitler wollte sie in sein konzept
eines großdeutschen reiches integrieren
nach dem krieg vertrieb die tschechisch
slowakische regierung diese deutschen
dann brutal und vereinnahmte ihr land
und ihren besitz
nun kann die tschechoslowakische armee
hier eine neue welle zerstörerischer
kraft freisetzen all die häuser schulen
und kirchen wurden für gefechts übungen
genutzt sie wurden mit großem kaliber
dem erdboden gleichgemacht
diese merkwürdigen kleinen häuser im
fels sind tatsächlich nur keller
die dazugehörige häuser darüber wurden
in die luft gesprengt
und das ist erst der anfang einer
rasanten veränderungen des geländes hin
zu einer modernen militär zone
im laufe der jahre nimmt die bedrohung
durch die sowjetunion immer weiter zu
bis dahin war dies der einzige staat
innerhalb des warschauer pakt ohne
stationierte sowjettruppen sie waren
überall in der ddr polen ungarn
bulgarien nur hier nicht am 21 august
1968 nach einer welle
antikommunistischer proteste ändert sich
das
dies ab jetzt ließen eine viertelmillion
soldaten in prag und anderen wichtigen
städten des landes einmarschieren
über die folgetage verdoppelte sich ihre
zahl
nach dieser machtdemonstration wurde
vertraglich festgehalten dass
75.000 sowjetische soldaten in der
region stationiert würden
diese stationierung erklärt die gebäude
hier
es waren unterkünfte für die familien
der piloten und offiziere der
sowjetischen armee
in einer zeit in der ost und west
einander mit völliger vernichtung drohen
macht die lage dieses stützpunkts ihn
für den fall eines kriegsausbruchs
strategisch wichtig
bis zu 20.000 sowjetische soldaten
lebten dort auf einem voll
ausgestatteten stützpunkt mit schulen
geschäften wohngebäuden und
arbeitsbereichen der bereits vorhandene
flugplatz wird zügig erweitert und es
entstehen booker ähnliche bauten um
modernste kampfflugzeuge zu tarnen die
sowjets bereiten sich auf eine neue art
von krieg vor
die mig 23 war eine große
weiterentwicklung sie war sehr
leistungsfähig und hätte einen
ernstzunehmenden gegner abgegeben noch
immer ist ein großer teil der hiesigen
geschichte um bekannt
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
wird langsam klar welche ausmaße das
wettrüsten tatsächlich angenommen hatte
ständig gibt es neue erschreckende
entdeckungen
nach dem abzug des militärs war dieses
250 quadratkilometer große gebiet über
und über mit scharfer munition bedeckt
wie stellt man es an so einen ort wieder
sicher zu machen
mehr als 130.000 teile scharfer munition
liegen herum oder sind im sand vergraben
václav bietet system hat die undankbare
aufgabe sie zu bergen
das war die wohl gefährlichste
munitionieren wenn sie gut erhalten war
und jemand den unvorsichtig damit um
konnte das eine ziemliche explosion
geben
in einem gebäude finden sich hinweise
darauf dass die sowjets möglicherweise
sogar noch unheilvolle hre kriegswaffen
entwickelten wenn man reingeht stößt man
auf diese seltsam aussehende maschine
dabei handelt es sich um einen autoklav
mit dem man geräte mittels hitze
dekontaminieren und sterilisieren kann
was auch immer sie damit taten
ungefährlich war das nicht
insgesamt erweisen sich rund 1,4
millionen kubikmeter erdreich als
verseucht
die sowjets hinterließen umweltschäden
in milliarden höhe
dennoch gehen sie nicht auf gesuche ein
unterstützung bei der bereinigung des
gebiets zu leisten
ein großteil des geländes ist zwar
geräumt aber es bleibt immer die gefahr
dass noch irgendwo unentdeckter munition
liegt es ist noch viel arbeit nötig um
es für die menschen vor ort
hundertprozentig sicher zu machen
bis heute ist nicht bekannt was die
sowjets ihr hinter verschlossenen türen
taten bevor nicht sämtliche unterlagen
aus der zeit des kalten kriegs
offengelegt sind wird der ort
geheimnisumwittert bleiben
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]